[Applaudissements]
son confinement jérôme rignault le vit
la plupart du temps dans son tracteur
cet exploitant basée à plaisir poursuit
son activité agricole malgré la crise
sanitaire préparation des semis de
céréales le programme de ce début de
saison printanier on vient de passer une
dizaine de jours avec un vent de
nord-est qui a vraiment tout ça tout à
ces chèques
donc c'est un petit peu assez ni les
terres sur les sur les premiers jours ça
nous a permis en bonne condition de
semer les orges de printemps les
féveroles moi je fais partie de ceux qui
font de la féverole c'est à dire la
protéine pour nos animaux
on se prépare par avance pour les ter à
maïs avant qu'elle sèche trop les
travailler en amont et on laisse aimera
d'ici une quinzaine de jours à peu près
à ses côtés de salariés sont engagés au
sein de son exploitation avec quelques
modifications dans l'organisation du
travail dans ce contexte particulier
chacun sa mission c'est vrai que
d'habitude on travaille beaucoup plus
ensemble
là c'est chacun sa mission son outil son
tracteur et puis dans une cabine au
moins toute la sécurité et la cette
crise entraîne aussi un changement de
regard sur l'agriculture
pour jérôme raynier au créateur de la
plateforme des changes
ici la terre cette période permet aux
français de réfléchir sur les produits
agricoles
on prend le temps de la réflexion prend
le temps de se poser et les gens ont
réalisé cette nécessité d'avoir une
agriculture locale responsable qui peut
le ramener des produits bien sûr
d'alimentation courante mais surtout de
qualité est garantie sanitaire
moralement on se sent un petit peu plus
apprécié je le vois par les coups de fil
qu'on reçoit sur le numéro vert mais je
vois aussi dans des publicités par des
messages de nos de nos élus ministres de
l'agriculture ministre de l'économie
face à la nécessité de main d'oeuvre
dans le secteur le ministre de
l'agriculture et la fnsea ont lancé un
appel aux personnes confinées pour aider
les agriculteurs sur leur exploitation